Speaker 1: All right, I teased this earlier, let's
let's get right to it. There is now a statement
that has been made by Republican Congresswoman
Liz Cheney, who is on the House Select Committee
Committee investigating the Jan. six riots.
She says they have firsthand testimony that
Ivanka Trump, among others. But Ivanka Trump, the
president, the former president's own daughter,
asked Donald Trump, Please do something to
stop these riots on January 6th. And of course,
he did not. And this continues to kind of
flesh out the picture that we are building
about exactly who did what and when on that day,
what were the goals, what were the intentions,
what were the priorities of different people?
And this is just unbelievable. Liz Cheney. We
have firsthand testimony. Ivanka asked
Trump to stop the Jan. six Capitol riot.
The House Select Committee investigating
the riots has received firsthand testimony
that Trump's daughter, Ivanka, twice asked him to
intervene. Trump was watching the riot unfold on
TV while sitting in the dining room next to
the Oval Office at the time. Let's go right
into the clips. This is Liz Cheney appearing
yesterday with George Stephanopoulos on ABC.
It is it's everything we imagined, guys.
Speaker 3: It's his failure to make
that statement criminal negligence.
Speaker 4: You know, I think that that there
are a number of, as the chairman said, potential
criminal statutes at issue here. But I think that
that there's absolutely no question that it was a
dereliction of duty. And I think one of the things
the committee needs to look at is we're looking at
a legislative purpose is whether we need enhanced
penalties for that kind of dereliction of duty.
Speaker 1: Now I want to be real. There's a
reason she's saying this, and this goes
back to what we talked about last week.
Officially, a congressional committees main
purpose can't be to figure out if someone
committed a crime. And Trump has tried to stop
the investigation by saying they're primarily
just looking to see if I committed a crime. Liz
Cheney is saying exactly what she has to say now,
whether it's true, or maybe they are primarily
looking at whether Trump committed a crime. But
at least what has to be said is our interest
is as lawmakers are there laws we need to pass
to prevent this from happening again if
we happen to come across crimes that were
committed in. So figuring that out, then we
can refer those crimes. There's if you saw
that segment last week, you understand the
legal relevance of that, but let's continue.
Speaker 4: But but I think it's also important for
the American people to understand how dangerous
Donald Trump was. We know as he was sitting
there in the dining room next to the Oval Office,
members of his staff were pleading with him
to go on television to tell people to stop.
We know Leader McCarthy was pleading with him
to do that. We know members of his family,
we know his daughter. We have firsthand testimony
that his daughter, Ivanka, went in at least twice
to ask him to please stop this
violence. Any man who would not do so,
any man who would provoke a violent assault on the
Capitol to stop the counting of electoral votes.
Any man who would watch television as police
officers were being beaten as as his supporters
were invading the capital of the United States is
clearly unfit for future office. Clearly can never
be anywhere near the Oval Office ever again.
Speaker 1: So this was a very interesting
and wide ranging interview. Let let's go to
another segment here where the topic is again.
At any point, Trump could have put a
stop to this any point, and he did not.
Speaker 3: We're joined now by the vice chair
of the committee, Congresswoman Liz Cheney.
Congresswoman Cheney, thank you for joining us
again this morning. Happy New Year to you. Know
you were alarmed by this from the very start,
from the moments to the first moments on January
six when this started to unfold, you've cut a
lonely path in your party. Have you been surprised
by anything you found over the last year?
Speaker 4: Well, I've certainly been surprised
by many things. I think that in the piece that
you played by Jon Karl just a few moments ago,
he touched on the fact that that we know now we
are learning much more about what former President
Trump was doing while the violent assault was
underway. The committee has firsthand testimony
now that he was sitting in the dining room next to
the Oval Office, watching the attack on television
as as the assault on the Capitol occurred. We
know as you, you know well that the briefing
room at the White House is just a mere few steps
from the Oval Office. The president could have at
any moment walked those very few steps into the
briefing room, gone on live television and told
his supporters who were assaulting the Capitol
to stop. He could have told them to stand down.
He could have told them to go home. And he failed
to do so. It's hard to imagine a more significant
and more serious dereliction of duty.
Speaker 1: It's funny to say he failed
because I mean, he didn't. He chose not
to do it. Failed almost didn't suggests
he wasn't able, but he chose not to. And two
thirds of the country and a lot of the world
asked the exact same questions Liz
Cheney is asking here, which is why?
Why not do it? And one last segment here
and again, this is this is Liz Cheney.
She's she's. But all power to her. She's saying
we have to be loyal here to the country, not
to Trump, and this isn't good for the Republican
Party. Liz Cheney is a right wing Republican with
whom I disagree on just about everything she voted
with Trump, something like 93 percent of the time.
But on this particular issue, she is correct
Speaker 3: here about a stalwart Republican
as I've ever met. You come from a long line of
Republicans as well. Of course, your father served
in the White House, your mother served in
administrations as well. How do you explain,
given your belief, your views in your
background, why a majority of Republicans today
would reelect Donald Trump?
Speaker 4: Look, I think that
we're in a situation as a nation where I certainly
have very strong disagreements with policies
of the Biden administration. I think that the
policies that Vice President and President Biden
has adopted are the wrong ones for this country. I
think we need conservative, principled leadership,
but the Republican Party has to make a choice. We
can either be loyal to our constitution or loyal
to Donald Trump, but we cannot be both, and the
nation needs a Republican party that is based on
substance and values and principles. And we've
got to get back to that if we want to get this
nation back on track. But fundamentally, at the
end of the day, we can't be a party that's based
on lies. We've got to be based on a foundation
of truth and fidelity to the rule of law.
Speaker 1: So listen, she's saying all the
right things, and I applaud her for it. I do.
This is still not someone who's going to be one of
our political allies. But would we be better off
if more Republicans saw Trumpism and their party
and country really as three different things,
and that you can be on the side of one or two of
those without having to stand by Donald Trump?
Of course, we would be better off. Of course,
we would be better off. So there is Liz Cheney,
Ivanka Ivanka firsthand testimony that Ivanka
multiple times tried to get Trump to do something,
and Trump didn't until hours later said in
a video, It's time to go home. We love you.
We know why you're here. It was stolen, but it's
time to go home. A completely pathetic, pathetic,
almost non reaction to the horrors of January
six and Trump will be doing a press conference
on Thursday, January 6th, the anniversary of
the riots, making some kind of statement. We
don't know what that will be, but we can be almost
certain it's going to be completely whacked out.